hey everyone I'm Anna Donlon and I'm the  executive producer of valor ins I'm Joe  Ziegler the game director first we want  to thank all of you for coming on this  journey with us all of you even those of  you that are still waiting to play are  the beginnings of a global community of  players that we hope to serve for years  or maybe even decades to come  your excitement for valor inspires us  every day and we've been looking forward  to sharing this game with everyone so  I'll get right to it earlier this year  when we reveal Valerie we also announced  a very aspirational launch date of  summer 2020 and we've been wanting to  get you this game to help brighten these  tough times but as it turns out we're  not going to be launching this game in a  few months because we're launching it in  a few weeks  [Music]